الانقسام معاكسه تضارب المصالح بين
مقاطعات بريطانيا الاربع وتجلى في نتائج
التصويت على في انجلترا راى القوميون
الانجليزي ان الخروج من الاتحاد الاوروبي
انتصار نفسي عظيم الانجليز كانوا الاكثر
حماسه باغلبيه اغلبيه
53.4 في اسكتلندا اي 62% البقاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبعد خروج بريطانيا من
الاتحاد الاوروبي عبر الاسكتلنديون عن عدم
رضاهم فاز الحزب الوطني الاسكتلندي
المطالب بالاستقلال عن التاج البريطاني
بسته وخمسين مقعدا برلمانيا في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه البريطانيه لعام 2015 قبل ان
يحقق اغلبيه كبيره في الانتخابات
البلمانيه الاسكتلنديه في العام الذي
تلاها 2016 في ايرلندا الشماليه تفوق
الجمهوريين كاثوليك الراغبون بالانضمام
لجمه ايرلندا على الوحدويون الوحدويين
البروتستانت الموالين البريطانيه التفوق
كان بنسبه
55.8 من المصوطين لخيار البقاء تحت مظله
بروكسيل لا تزالوا الاغلبيه في ويلز تدعم
البقاء مع بريطانيا على الرغم من استفاده
ويلز من الاتحاد الاوروبي بحوالي
245 مليون جنيه استرليني سنويا حينها
واقعا انعكس في تصويت
52.5% من الوالدين لصالح الخروج من
الاتحاد الاوروبي